Actually we're up to the question if we have got you.
More years of the ruling
or if you already meant always had to be going at all because the thought of your first meeting will force.
I think it was a I know it. First of the party. We have meaningful prayer in the. Woman.
Much of one very elegant movements of a page three. Or for a man. And I really don't hear a actually.
And here you are merely get referred to for.
Not freely not overtly I think possibly was too large for purpose here is where I showed you before.
So you know enough by a for was four years for proud of the From thing all day and.
He was very demanding over the yes I have just a good day and. You were sent over to the side of ready.
Yes and he did decide things for her that I think Theo is the leader best get him out on the she did her job
but I think you will have basket basket. Made of us get him out if you are having He did a thing.
And a man called how Tom some Americans became our Also most vocal come out with no such thing as characteristic what
you do. And everything you say. The first of the year. If you need it. And wages me in my eyes days you have asterisks.
And. How very very much about. And he said that like you to do my after it. There are twelve of them.
And we put the very long in those so I was there for a long Gross is a very I was ready. And they were great.
But it was something simply because you read that they really should read it and they would just encourage From move
but they only have her back to us and he does this thing and. How Thompson they know was American.
He was quite right he was. Part she had gray and he had quite severe.
And he was passing but out of the five of those you have a look back
and I have a note from it was our way of old man but it was five scheme. In this way here.
And this American voice of most. Use could come fish. I think we would go in the car and.
He stayed up
and he have whereby I have a go at a fair I think we should call it right we're going to close in on how home. And.
Then I went into the army. And I had a lot because I was just local I Fers Argo were a little on what he thought.
I was stationed to fish. I was sent first to the red light. When I was your about when I went away early.
I was given you to give him a panic on the you thing. And you're off. So I'd like to go home.
So you're off and we were not very long but she just said winds with the family way. From the very end on the way to.
Single them. I'm losing my arms. That's when I did the camp come over feeling I was to show you all that work.
Oh oh yes. Lovely day all my ADD about my what I was the girl in the thing was there for roll.
Oh any route are for the way go oh and i lack the lack of good. Will we didn't know I was a good move.
We can't have a camera. Oh about twelve months say every weekend we have all.
I was so far I have to say I wish to be billeted in the signal from. Them coming up. Next few hours. Saji.
I'll be in the front tire. Or. Oh we'll. Oh have you there. Gary I have those that have a life that only takes. Right.
Hold with you. You know I think you have all the might work for you.
Yes you very very few hours away from him for life. Right. OK.
Quickly with so much working very good year ago and I were in camp and I was able to throw in pair.
With care at the back of our house. And be on ROOM. And happy all the time for the long haul.
When I already and I would have the washer was for us. Well I'm having a very much.
I shall be doing this show what I say are my kind of age where young luge young.
Found Brady and most of you a few years. Well OK maybe just OK. They was right and that's for me.
Havelock house buying the A single and then we were in who were who were called him before you meet the right.
And I was Cheryl as a model but. It was my hook up with the clacking misleading them about a half equity book.
I'm really lucky that I have a lot of the most Yeah OK. Never say that all.
Russian forces there are folks saying oh we went well. Or something. Well good luck So karma.
Very much talking about that was a ploy on I would be a study where I had a year in the house.
That's where I met Jimmy are almost all. Oh you need to go away here to America. Held for five years.
It would be more you know.
If you were giving me I volunteered for this but one of my friends should go but I have to draw him out
and I did not because I haven't had that house. I didn't my way over a guy you finish row source. Kind of.
When you saw. Right. Wall.
You know what it was really because I was in the infantry had to go
but I never mousetraps you out if you have to so motivated even close with things like natural forces fighting.
You know giving up being the four people.
Out of corporate media playing the other game sharking when you go places you.
Have terrible losses through for our for my to play not for I suppose hopes of thank you for your lies. So yeah. But.
I think I can vouch for a very. Well yes that this was going to use it because it was rationing on me.
And in my position not get anything right. About my remark California terrible things change.
Do you have a cite for that stuff and focus on some of the all very. I've never seen it. And I'm bringing rush.
Back anything by my hands off if it was OK. And I very much about him. Also saying how Holmes.
And it was how come some of our very cool stuff was America.
I think most of the head of the jail is not a day old
and show off of half took a long while getting some of the most I was watching if I was first starting it was just
while he went back to America.
Yeah I was flying over to the coast foremost
and I was in the air all the way to go you know what you have you got all you got that he was up
and you know he was shot down by one of a hero in a shoot because you know you also hear what I didn't get a while that
he was here when we knew. Although I came up. If I got some legs out get help and then I work a go it well.
There are the most where you go but I was worried about him early help him out and I was local heroes
and both play right. So I'm just. Good thing being in the side sort of business.
Here is a very one hour year where little rifles are another very limited way in love and we saw a play about.
I thank God for them because of something I want
and you can really get my business sense for really really care about this sort of matter.
He didn't care about money
and he vowed that never coming home a lot more familiar with how go more smoothly with fear
and fear you think I may very well because of their own almost family behind me though about Harry are some go away
because there's nothing for the boy in Yiddish to replace say I'm my mother you can have a car.
That didn't worry you never worry if you little room or how any more so for every serve you.
If you are sick she said if you can then we shall of course if you are going to mark out can't work
and he said let me know if a friend of emotion and I hate come back over.
Although the hate before the war he had a gruesome crash. They will learn to live with this for what he had briefly.
And when he came back there were no group. So I say it for all right you coming with me.
Although I love my house and you have a house to move. And I pay for Simon Amstell. The farmer.
I didn't bargain anything useful with it was you know it. And then we Chinese there to more stupid.
You know with you about months of frozen and. We were in the work place this and that was so quick it was so.
You go for it but when we went to vote for you what we're learning what we were we were lucky house in a way.
And we knew right away and we do which if you're saying we think we have it and then we get it
and we go in there with it. Right. And if you feel very good.
Oh yeah we did all that for the right away then we'll go back and lock them out lovely house. I think.
And we stitch up again.
I know maybe things will go up again
when I had my A short time after four years because I say work had nothing that is for the bench.
Thank you set me back from him by referring to that we were joined from Michael Kay very mellow and I thank you for.
Price. Oh you for the visuals so reduced price paid money. And. There's little way down the way.
When you're more from the movie fish. And you say I'm seventy three. You're going to look ridiculous really.
If you believe what I did because there's nothing else wrong. This is me.
I said you were oh so funny is I think part of low you know you get war style.
Oh yeah a little certain way and I know you. I mean I saw what might happen.
But you say I can I Didn't you see I work for how Thompson.
It was a little while ago of those who believe they are my movie Those would be good for all the goodies.
This will help with yardwork a first. I knew he had nobody else. So and I knew it was about faith and I thought well.
If you get a start a lot of forcing going on. I think admiration for essential.
Isn't Enough so you might eventually say. He said he's nice. You know. So. Well not because she's right.
Most of the fight in the face moment because he's yours had some go all right. Meet him. It didn't really matter.
I went on I know even in the beginning.
You're in the room the thought you know where you were all of you have a quote about staying.
But when all you folks want to be a vessel and I so often with this kind of way
but you can't you people never have never have I'm going to move it where I know where it all is another sort of
personality. One of say passive main part of why I'm so well because I'm not.
Maybe there's something out on the table and you do knock you know for forty you measure get a sixty five.
Roger course. With you know all the more we don't know if you have many things or by the way of psychosis.
But you know if anything half of one of those. With the station because you rely on each other to do it. Where are you.
What are you doing all that sort of thing you say. And it's a pleasure motion machine a goodish if you are very sure.
I bet each of you go off.
I mean I go to the Roman bowels Prado I'm sure they hate they ever think they may be enjoying it back home.
You see especially when that was my wife sort of you know when they see it more from a really cool for a moment
when they were all there with you know back on the hook for a little bit worse by the side of yes yes.
Oh yeah I think a lot of us when I when I was he really made my day long about friendship not the crush
and then much of it was a little like now you know all the so you know it was a little bit like now I think that the
show even though you go and he's OK you know he's probably twenty four hopefully you will think you were fulfilling.
So I think you said every way you agree and I think there is.
I have a desk and that gives you a little bit of your safety. And when we sold the business and going straight.
To some Amish people with love. For me we had a part of it.
I was just like but I had my share of a lot of having for nothing.
And since we were from and as I said I mean go home and then we sew through an English house.
And I think we just got on a very good. If you find it in you. I didn't hear you.
We'll a slow go with your book or you know and we took some or you have a way
and we have a friend here have some rooms. It's great. Just down from our place.
And they aware in a way John was saying one of those I was playing about in the orange tree the rock on top of him.
Oh so you know exactly what world of pedophiles Shar you know and she had the rapes and she
when you knew something about everything and she was a little bit of a nice guy live for ever. The family.
And she was right. So we come right over if you see you. You bought it.
You are you pushing away our future here passenger progress
and more about what you want if you're going to sort of what was right.
And we had I know a few mountains to finish up our way. And then we went three fourths of way.
Or maybe forty eight not having a political battle over in fifty years here. He won't forgive me right.
If you wish he would but if she were where you were going and they went on a great ship.
He was very little very few who say this Bucky who and what I am by what they are like offset all that much house.
And then I saw the problem when I was very sick from Mexico shingles all. OK And I remember this fucking. Rifle.
From other. Shoot. Should I have to get out our stock market. And there's a big crowd get out.
We're going to have to go with off the car said this is not the army.
I'm paying to go on this back a vessel went past South Africa on that. OK Well that was.
Anyhow arriving who will give you advice I should have tried to have thought OK well. I eighty years.
Because of the everything I visit business I would all have a lot of radio on this. Are my mate from a few years.
And I said to me after I had already seen your family be this back and have a for me. I have sorry courage.
I can't tell you what I think I owe you but you have to pay for everything.
So our actions must get rid of way and I couldn't bear the local going up this character.
Are the same areas that my fate will. Families leave you broke.
And she goes out he was there live with love the Big House to be and smoke free will. It's you. Yes I'm here. And.
I'm don't forget to head over on the ship was a blue final and I was a very kind of people and they hear those women.
Well too serious for them. We were just living with them for. A very high pitched thought on the way we watched them.
We got very friendly they were nice and we think we can just say most of them.
You know frame of mind house where I found myself in a career. With that if you know me.
I should be where I said terrible. Care of all cases the family your friends fast be very rich possible.
Actually I think are well by hell with rationing that are a very friendly with the actual.
And I stand back to share how I use a very very big box full of spaghetti bowl and I have a big I use something else.
My goodies that came with me on but I prefer to try. I know we have so much to get in common. Well and good and you.
OK. More of the direction we're pretty close and both of us to you.
For that but as you know we as we think trying to figure out what. We think right. Little Blue. With no use of it is.
We both are we have. Some of the station away from film and I can say I think.
For one thing and in those days it was for export in the shape of clothes.
You got to take it very well and that made a way and it didn't matter. But it was coming back to US radio with Rachel.
Eventually for years over a period. And the number was K. Six now no more than I had to have be eggs something.
Six years and that was a.
Oh yes my little bit little word that you would grow because we were there if we have problems first.
When we put the remote in writing in Mom's and we have a right where they go on with the really really good.
Jackie who you know my girl will. Really like to do. I did say R.J. I wish. Mary back in my. Rock. You know.
I was thinking. Mark Rasch Harlow's faces that they're going to replay. Their goal for us all.
And I suppose there were there were sort of a boy those it was another one now versus where you. At the festival.
There was a local boy this girl in the last one was looking the low said. Something. For. Back question via.
That woman rather good. Thank you. I am very good very very they aren't very gifted you've got a good memory.
Never survived for all those years ago lost your job you're through with the flu.
If you believe in the law for those who think. Well we will go with you. We will go.
Over our very slow route I go to Russia and I go out my head. And I used to go to the head of all leave our.
Little Eva and I have carried one. So where's my house my head our clothes. Haha.
Well a good idea without having to have those cracks about things we wish all go well for all of them will.
Of very little solution if you are going to see if you still cross the road that you live in for the movie looking for
the truth Cuomo rules for the lottery you are in their numbers wonderful for this market.
However I think you know her way through. I have a use for.
Where you will host hopefully the most well off one of your you give it to the kids with Marlo to walk the walk through
to the he disappears. You saw them all looking at our no ordinary. Parka for years.
And I knew we lovers Jimmy Hall to me. Are you afraid I would be here with a friend for you to hear everybody.
Now you're OK yes with me. Now are they going to hear all of you do I hear oh yeah this is it.
Here CD is yes he did his return for you so very well. Well. Well you know.
It now or seven with the love you all now are fascinated by it suited me and he was different.
You know not allowed to go oh yes and that just lark. Have what he did everything. When we collectors with. Or.
What you more girl would go into those in the lives of people all over the world with very little.
I think because of was hot and I was off the bass track.
You know and I didn't think he'd ever been not there have been and we just thought. Yes.
And so on here good but places. From. This to rehearsal where you could forget those things. Could last. Yes.
So right where you is from so. Anyway our century power a bit.
Give me your sense for the role of high tech you in here as a whole. And. He literally P.S.C.
Defeat in my house when the phone number. They have asked for and he would write my name with a word of year.
You do a year day by somebody like me like me. Then move on.
You always love those books with a job getting to vote the way you look at what we got you got about as you thought
about from.
It dropped you off a truck you are trying throw you off somebody for a map Victoria you go there was about to make sure
that took you down.
But you will know so before we go it looks OK we have a way here we go on the floor of the behavior only about Rio De
Witt so. I think we've moved from the Occupy way from the group.
You know they're really having a very somber lately we've been in a mood like in the way we have Friday night.
People who are very kind of aware of this. For mercy moving it away. Everybody can carry him some way.
So we have a way of. Course get a call on the plane. If you live here.
Yes we are sitting at the back and we have a great call for you.
Have a great effect fool
and we've written beautiful shit back to you because we've recorded it with a drawing of the past.
Three hours for your carefree. I never took umbrage. I did for you. Very good. Thank you very much.
Which bit I have to thank you thank you.
I think I was income I think I knew I could have I think this riches and all those years in the Army with us.
Offices for I knew. I have the upper hand. I knew I was right there with the way when I was stronger.
For the good will you. In fact I would give before even when I was of this.
If you if we wouldn't be in pain in and drive are you think fit me right in the eye of the slave. Cause I knew.
If it didn't suit here more something for ten. Well you know I knew you had to play with.
An obvious sense that the other person walked and you are really feeling.
When you move your face on the station then you are you sure he wished he was with you if you. Did you.
Again you were going to save me actually wasn't if it was him.
Bill because I went to him but I don't know what he was taking him home because a second but you are right
and we met and he was going to stay with his brother and she's from for most of them and told him.
Just from the way things go wrong out here. Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh. Many years we are very very very very good.
We will move as far as you can say yes. Longstanding yes yes yes. All of the years ago.
Oh yes oh
and you of all there are your hopes to move with the good things will be of those he was in the Air Force you know you
will and then after the war while he went to melt one of us have our see him
but we are you going to stay with we pray for him.
He had a laugh as he has lived in way through most of you so you might think for half a nice day
and he does so with your little girl all. Now I did in fact he liked me very.
Much in that sea because that most think well what's going on.
Not so much what's going on here but I think right now we may have that
and it just sort of was a question of sort of right.
I never had any contact with you because if he did the fear of me by more grateful.
I think through the fear here and here we think oh it's always a good place you can really do it you know
and then I had lots of women the firing was a good thing having karma thing where you really need a basket.
He was a little space. Oh cool. There are. We have so much. You say.
Do you think this way you'll go and I need you to work with me. And you know.
And she was very merry going over it just so beautiful.
Oh you have a little laughter if you work with their home as a way of living. You will fall in love with you.
Yes I think we will still have reasonable.
You know you've got to give back your life you know a lot you know you work so hard right now
and I are going to tell Mark.
I think you can have fun with this it really wasn't a lot of my career have been really you know yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
a lot. He's going to say you know. Thank you. OK OK Well I mean. OK I want or I mean. Oh yes you know. Thank you.
Thank you all very good pot. The big blow the ball club but thank you. A good way. Thank you thank you.
Oh OK OK OK OK OK OK. Oh my God yes.
Net zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero OK OK.
Well you know and I was like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh oh oh oh oh.